if you had to choose one cartoon animal
to have sex with who would it be
well obviously old Lola Bunny that's
easy yeah a lot of people go with that
damn those you're big there's a fox
there's a fox in like a oh the Robin
Hood yeah Mary Magdalene no no not that
one
yes that's the one I'm talking about oh
zootopia yeah and I think there's a
bunny that's what I'm thinking with a
bunny rabbit Robin Hood Mary Magdalene
from the Disney Mary Mary
magdalene's Bible
all the animals in zootopia I would
finish in them oh yeah I just got into
that dude I'll say it right now
normal in front of Garfield who's normal
no no normal the hottest piece Jim Davis
ever drew the rabbits from Watership
Down
[Laughter]
I guess I wanna grab it Minnie Mouse
Minnie Mouse can get it should catch it